zdf heute live mit einer sondersendung
zur pressekonferenz der union
unions-bundestagsfraktion der neu
gewählten die ja ziemlich große
schwierigkeiten hat heute gab es viele
diskussionen darum wie es weitergehen
soll mit unter anderem diesem herrn hier
ralph brinkhaus bis jetzt war er der
vorsitzende der bundestagsfraktion es
gab diskussionen und jetzt gibt's an der
pressekonferenz wir hatten mal rein
mittag gesagt dass das die woche der
entscheidungen ist sowohl inhaltlich wie
personell ich hätte ganz gerne gewußt
haben nach dieser entscheidung für ein
brinkhaus die personellen entscheidungen
abgeschlossen sind für diese woche oder
ob weitere kommen die sie uns ankündigen
können und was heißt dass herr trikots
für die stellung von herr laschet
angesichts der heftigen diskussionen die
es ja auch in der fraktion um seine
person und verantwortung gab
ja zu ihrer ersten frage wir haben heute
eine zentrale ganz wichtige
personalentscheidung getroffen in der
fraktion ich habe ja auch darauf
gedrängt dass wir diese entscheidung
heute treffen da hat sie auch an anderer
stelle diskussionen gegeben und ich bin
sehr froh dass wir eine gemeinsame
sichtweise hier an den tag gelegt haben
und diese wichtige entscheidung
getroffen haben das ist für diese woche
schon mal ganz gut glaube ich weitere
habe ich jetzt nicht aktuell
anzukündigen an personalentscheidungen
ja und ansonsten ist es so dass wir
jetzt in gespräche reingehen werden
gespräche anbieten werden und das ist
ganz klar das ist natürlich alle diese
funktionen sind eingebunden sind und es
ist so dass wir als fraktion aber schon
sagen wir wollen eine starke stellung
haben wir wollen damit reden und wir
werden auch nicht jedem kompromiss
mitmachen sondern wir wollen unser
markenkern halten ich habe das heute
mittag auch schon mal gesagt und das ist
jetzt der weg wie wir jetzt in gespräche
dann rein gehen werden und natürlich ist
es so dass die beiden parteivorsitzenden
da eine zentrale rolle spielen vielen
dank frau lau von derzeit ihre frage
bitte sie uns ein bisschen mehr über die
diskussionen erzählen die stattgefunden
haben
also ich fand sie eigentlich relativ
sachlich die diskussion es ist ja so ich
sag das ja ganz offen da sei es
natürlich viele enttäusche kolleginnen
und kollegen im saal einige die ja auch
super super lange für die fraktion
gearbeitet haben die sich der tolle
eingebracht haben die nicht
wiedergewählt worden sind und insofern
war es also insgesamt eine sehr
sachliche diskussion im breiten
meinungsspektrum sicherlich war die eine
oder andere enttäuschung braucht dabei
da brauchen wir uns auch überhaupt
nichts vormachen aber es hat sich dann
doch gezeigt dass in der krise dann doch
irgendwo der zusammenhalt dann
entsprechend da ist und insofern war das
auch gut und wichtig und es müssen ja
auch sachen auch einfach mal
ausgesprochen werden das gehört ja auch
dazu kann ja jetzt nicht irgendwie so
tun als wenn alles normal ist und wie
eine ganz normale legislaturperiode
haben es ist schon sehr ungewöhnlich
aber es war also ganz ganz überwiegend
vom willen getragen es nach vorne zu
schauen im zentrum der diskussionen
stand so kann man das glaube ich sagen
dass es seine
bereitschaft gibt verantwortung zu
übernehmen
dass das aber nicht mit einem ausverkauf
der eigenen positionen und
eigenen
themenbereiche einhergehen kann
und darüber hat sich haben wir mal sehr
viel in der debatte gedreht dass die
richtige balance gehalten werden muss
aus verantwortung einerseits und der
glaubwürdigkeit der eigenen positionen
auf der anderen seite und dass es dann
in einem gesamtbild natürlich dazu
gehört dass auch aufarbeitung von den
vergangenen monaten stattfindet das auch
das eine oder andere an kritische
bemerkung stattfindet glaube ich ist
sogar notwendig und zwingend und
deswegen über die einzelnen
wortmeldungen geben wir hier ja keine
auskunft aber ich habe den verdacht dass
sie die ohnehin irgendwo mitbekommen
haben stimmt herr feldhof vom zweiten
deutschen fernsehen ihre frage bitte
wenn ich das richtig sehe richtig
beurteile ist ja den vorschlag von der
brinkhaus zur wahl von beiden
parteivorsitzenden gemeinsam in einem
kompromiss vorgeschlagen worden warum
sind die beiden parteivorsitzenden jetzt
nicht hier um ihnen zu gratulieren und
trägt dann antwort zu stehen
na ja also wir haben so gratuliert auch
sehr nett und es ist ja jetzt so eine
sache das ist eine sache der fraktion
ist das heißt also wir sind die
fraktionen wir sind auch so
selbstbewusst dass da für uns selber
sprechen können und ich glaube ist auch
das richtige zeichen ja das war jetzt
ergeben dass wir selber sprechen das ist
ganz freundschaftlich wir haben uns da
abgesprochen und haben gesagt wir beiden
machen das und insofern sind die beiden
anderen jetzt schon zu weiteren
gesprächen unterwegs das soll ja ganz
gute arbeitsteilung ich kann ihnen
versichern dass
beide parteivorsitzenden auch ohne
fotobeweis ralph brinkhaus persönlich
gratuliert haben
die nächste frage frau hasenkamm von der
südwest presse
ich habe noch mal eine frage zu den
koalitionsverhandlungen was ist denn
jetzt die linie nach dieser
fraktionssitzung herr brinker sie haben
gerade gesagt sie werden gespräche
anbieten den csu-chef habe ich vorhin so
verstanden dass sozusagen jetzt erstmal
abgewartet wird ob jemand nach
möglicherweise gescheiterter ampel auf
sie zukommt aber sie klang jetzt gerade
wieder als ob sie aktiv werden wollen na
ja also ich meine
wir müssen ja unsere
gesprächsbereitschaft signalisieren ja
das gehört ja dazu also ich meine werden
ja jetzt auch sagen können also
gesprächen mit niemand wir sind
beleidigt und haben jetzt irgendwo keine
lust mit jemandem zu sprechen das
entspricht aber nicht unseren
verantwortungsgefühl und das ist ja auch
das was in der fraktionssitzung in
vielen vielen wortbeiträgen gekommen ist
dass wir verantwortung übernehmen wollen
und übernehmen müssen das heisst also
jetzt nicht dass wir das aus einer
position raus machen so hallo wir
organisieren das jetzt sondern aus einer
position heraus machen wo wir sagen als
demokratische partei stehen wieder zur
verfügung
wir würden gerne sprechen wir würden
auch gerne verantwortung übernehmen und
alles andere wird sich jetzt ergeben
weil wir ja auch eine sehr ungewöhnliche
konstellation haben das muss man auch
sagen insofern über keinen widerspruch
zwischen dem was ich gesagt habe und was
markus söder gesagt hat absolut es
handelt sich auch nicht um
koalitionsverhandlungen sondern
sondierungen um die es jetzt geht und
wir haben heute besprochen dass wir
aktiv unsere gesprächsbereitschaft
anmelden
und das heißt jetzt nicht nur über die
medien und über die öffentlichkeit
unsere gesprächsbereitschaft formulieren
sondern dass wir sie auch aktiv
gegenüber
möglichen sondierungs partnern zu
erkennen geben die nächste frage frau
dunst von redaktions netzwerk
deutschland bitte
das ist hier irgendwie so so zierte die
mikrofone wir sind auf das andere frage
an sie beide in welchem zeitrahmen
bewegt sich das was sie gerade gesagt
haben dass sie ihre
gesprächsbereitschaft anmelden läuft das
parallel zu dem was union was grüne und
fdp mit der spd plan und wäre in solchen
verhandlungen herr laschet für sie der
geeignete verhandler oder würde sich das
auf herrn söder konzentrieren und herr
laschet damit er den weg freimachen
müssen
also wir sind ein team wir haben das
auch gerade in der fraktionssitzung im
team gemacht das ist armin laschet das
ist markus söder das ist alexander
dobrindt das ist ralph brinkhaus weil
die fraktion noch eine starke rolle
spielen will und auch eine starke rolle
spielen muss und insofern betrachten wir
uns da als mannschaft
niemand verhandelt alleine das habe ich
heute nachmittag ja auch hier betont
es kann nur gemeinsame verhandlungen
geben sowohl was die beiden parteien
anbelangt als auch was die fraktion
anbelangt die parteien können ohne die
fraktionsführung
diese sondierungen auch nicht
durchführen da legen wir auch absoluten
wert darauf das war auch heute in der
fraktionssitzung sehr sehr deutlich dass
es einen ausgesprochen beteiligungs
wunsch der fraktionen an diesen
möglichen sondierungen gibt weil das
auch genau der sicherung des markenkerns
von cdu und csu auch in verhandlungen
dienen soll und dementsprechend auch
nachdruck verleihen soll ergebnis von
verhandlungen kann am schluss ja auch
nur mit der zustimmung einer fraktion
erfolgen und deswegen legen wir auch der
besondere wert drauf und das heißt genau
so kann man das sehen niemand verhandelt
alleine es geht um die beiden
parteivorsitzenden
es geht um den fraktionsvorsitzenden der
vorsitzende der csu im deutschen
bundestag das sind diejenigen die da
vorhanden
naja gut
jetzt kenne ich den zeitrahmen der ampel
sondierungen nicht weiß nicht ob sie ihn
kennen aber dazu habe ich ja keine
einladung das heißt also das kann jetzt
keine abschließende antwort auf diese
frage geben ich habe gesagt es geht um
relativ schnell wir haben einen kurzen
zeitplan vor augen es braucht klarheit
in der öffentlichkeit wir können jetzt
keine hängepartie brauchen das würde
auch die mögliche zustimmung zu egal
welcher konstellation in der
öffentlichkeit nicht vergrößern sondern
verkleinern wir haben alle noch im kopf
wie vor vier jahren die
verhandlungen waren da hat man sich aus
sondierungen heraus
übergangslosen koalitionsverhandlungen
hinein entwickelt das wird dieses mal
erkennbar nicht so sein also das wird
nach sondierungen natürlich auch einen
bruch geben und dann wird man sehen
welche koalitionsverhandlungen wie
aufgenommen werden können und allein das
bedingt schon dass es nur einen sehr
sehr schmalen zeitplan geben kann in
denen man diese sondierungen abschließen
muss wir reden hier nicht über mehrere
wochen uns sehr deutlich zu sagen die
nächste frage herr die ziehen vom
deutschlandradio bitte
herrn dobrindt können sie mit der
klarheit diese gerade versprochen haben
auch sagen dass armin laschet nach wie
vor in den gesprächen diese führen
wollen der kanzlerkandidat der union und
auch der cdu/csu es
ich habe jetzt überhaupt keine anderen
andeutungen irgendeine richtung gemacht
wir verhandeln gemeinsam jeder in seiner
position didier aktuell auch wahrnimmt
meine damen und herren herzlichen dank
für ihr interesse
danke schön schön amt
ich glaube dabei erkennen war noch eine
frage die das jetzt nicht abwürgen dr
lose bitte
[Musik]
herrn brinkhaus warum haben sie nicht
darauf bestanden für das glückliche
volle jahr gewählt zu werden
naja es war ja eine situation wo es auch
darum gehen geschlossenheit zu zeigen
und da ist es dann so gewesen dass wird
an uns darauf geeinigt haben oder die
parteivorsitzenden das also entsprechend
vorgeschlagen haben dass wir das bis zum
30 10 vierten machen und dann sehen wir
auch entsprechend weiter aber ich habe
da viel freude daran und ich werde mich
bemühen dass nach dem 30 10 vierten
weiterzumachen
dank
herr druck und gerade sie wollte ich
fragen sie haben es mehrfach zu tun
heute muss man die jungs sind ja nicht
nicht preis geben werde bitte was sie
haben mehr von entschuldigung sie haben
mehrfach betont heute dass die union in
vereinen möglichen verhandlungen den
markenkern der union nicht preis geben
werde können sie kurz umreißen was ist
der markenkern um den star geht
ein kurzer kann ich es nicht lang kann
ich das sehr wohl aber
wir haben ja deutlich gemacht dass es
uns wenn wir jetzt in sondierung filmen
um auch darüber drei große elemente geht
über die man diskutieren muss das eine
ist wirtschaftliches wachstum und neue
dynamik die geschaffen werden muss
der themenbereich klimaschutz und
beschleunigung des
klimaschutzes ist uns auch ein großes
anliegen und natürlich in diesem rahmen
ein wichtiger gesprächspunkt wenn man
hier vereinbarungen finden müsste und
der dritte punkt ist die sicherheit
äußere und innere sicherheit
bündnisfähigkeit verlässlichkeit in
internationalen angelegenheiten die in
so einem rahmen diskutiert werden müsste
dann haben wir noch zwei fragen
entschuldigung zum abschluss ok herr
ziegler von der stuttgarter zeitung
bitte
es gibt ja viele auch in ihrer fraktion
die sagen wir müssten eigentlich die
reihenfolge einhalten erst wird über die
ampel verhandelt und wenn das nicht
zustande kommt müssten wir als
zweitplatzierte uns dann programmatisch
anbieter ist ab alternative aber eben
erst wenn die ampel sozusagen
ausverhandelt ist oder aus sondiert ist
söder hat sicherheit nachmittag auch
dahingehend geäußert dass
olaf scholz die besseren kanzler chancen
hat warum tut sich die union so schwer
da eine gemeinsame linie zu finden war
jetzt wird ja eben doch offensichtlich
parallel sondiert
also wir haben gesagt wir bieten unsere
gesprächsbereitschaft an und das gehört
sich auch so als demokratische partei
und natürlich haben wir ein interesse
daran dass wir eine koalition mit formen
können und jetzt muss man einfach
schauen jetzt ist es so dass sich die
liberalen und den grünen zusammen setzen
wie gesagt unser angebot steht jetzt
schauen wir mal was sich entwickelt weil
wir sind ja jetzt wirklich nicht in
einer situation wo es irgendwie so
klassisch ist weil wir haben ja schon
ein komisches wahlergebnis das muss man
ja sagen also ist nicht sehr dicht
beieinander ist in zwei koalition
möglich es ist so dass zwei kleine
partner irgendwo immer dabei sind in den
beiden koalitionsoptionen und das ist
sehr ungewöhnlich und dementsprechend
müssen sie auch damit rechnen dass in
dieser woche auch das nicht unbedingt
alles irgendwo wie auf schienen passiert
und jetzt schauen wir mal einfach was in
den nächsten tagen passiert und
vielleicht ist ja eins auch richtig ja
wir haben ja jetzt
konstituierte als fraktion die anderen
fraktionen haben dass da so größtenteils
auch gemacht deshalb heute ist dann auch
die arbeitsfähigkeit dann entsprechend
also in der neuen konstellation
hergestellt wir schauen was die nächsten
tage so bringen und vielleicht ist ja
auch noch nicht angenommen also sie
stellen die frage an uns warum macht ihr
parallel oder eins nach dem anderen oder
der erst die ampel dann jamaika oder
umgekehrt das hängt ja nicht an uns
sondern wir geben unser angebot ab wir
würden gerne diese gespräche führen aber
jetzt waren welche termine stattfinden
hängt er sehr stark auch vom jeweiligen
gesprächspartner ab und dazu stehen wir
dann die antworten entsprechend aus so
dass man diese frage
gleichzeitig hintereinander erst nach
den ersten kontaktaufnahmen beantworten
kann und ich kann ihnen sagen wenn man
die fraktion sich anschaut dann ist der
wille dieser fraktion da dass diese
gespräche stattfinden und die frage in
welcher reihenfolge das macht steht im
hintergrund da hat jeder so seine idee
dazu aber dazu gibt es jetzt keine
abschließenden vereinbarungen sondern
wir sind sehr interessiert daran dass
man das jetzt mit der fdp mit den grünen
zu gesprächen geführt aber wie dies
zustande kommen hängt auch von unseren
möglichen regierungspartnern und hier
vorne die letzte frage bitte
afrika ist heute nachmittag vor der
sitzung war von einem kompromiss für
eine halbes jahr die rede bis zum 30
viertens wenn ich mir nicht verrechnet
habe sieben monate bereits über einzelne
monate gefälscht oder was hat es damit
auf sich da wohl nicht gefallen schon da
wurde gerundet und es ist so dass der
bundestag sich am 26 oktober
konstituiert und das kann man jetzt
irgendwie so oder so sehen aber das hier
ist echt geil thema gewesen also wir
haben da jetzt nicht um tage quatsch das
ist nicht sehr weit gefasst
so aber ist ein guter grundsatz die
rundung ist die lösung ja danke schön
alles gute
ja die rundung ist die lösung sagte er
und verschwand von der bühne das war ein
extra dobrindt der csu-landesgruppenchef
zusammen mit dem gerade frisch im amt
bestätigten ralph brinkhaus de ist
fraktionsvorsitzender der
unions-bundestagsfraktion aber wir haben
es gerade gehört nur für ein halbes jahr
nicht viel ein jahr wie das
normalerweise immer gemacht wird was
dahinter steckt wie wir diesen auftritt
herz zu bewerten haben das bespreche ich
mit und politikexperten den
politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf korte
der uns jetzt hoffentlich zugeschaltet
ist dass sie dank einer schönen guten
abend herr sehen kann sich ja immer so
wir hatten eigentlich damit gerechnet so
haben wir auch hier diese nur
angekündigt dass herr söder und herr
laschet vor die presse treten in ihrer
funktion als parteivorsitzender und ja
seit zwei tagen im dauerfeuer seit für
das wahlergebnis haben jetzt sind die
nicht gekommen was ist das für ein
signal in ihren augen
naja was wir sehen sind szenarien des
machtverfall so würde ich das einordnen
da muss ja offenbar jeder millimeter
erobert werden aus lasse
sich doch so durchzusetzen dass er
überhaupt den anspruch erhalten kann als
verhandlungspartner zur verfügung zu
stehen das deutet nicht viel darauf hin
dass er große unterstützung habe mir
einmal uns überlegen wie wirklichkeit
ein großer wahlsieger mit viel
unterstützung verhandeln würde dann
wären diese themen überhaupt nicht
wichtig sondern dann wäre ganz klar von
ihm bestimmt worden ein großer boden
schwer fraktionsvorsitzender wird und
der werder noch einmal für ein jahr
gewählt worden oder aber er wäre wie in
andere situation kommissarisch das ich
will dass sich selbst um dann ein ganz
starkes verhandlungsmandat zu haben für
kommende verhandlung das sind jetzt
szenarien diesen früheren zeiten gab all
das ist nicht erfolgt das zeigt das
erringen muss um jeden millimeter die
haben ein komisches wahlergebnis hat
ralph brinkhaus gerade gesagt
haben wir in der tat aber wenn wir mal
in die europäischen nachbarländer gucken
dann ist das eigentlich doch da schon
lange so
das heißt sind wir deutschen sind
deutschland ist deutschland das 1
mittlerweile auch meinem 21 jahrhundert
angekommen und hat es so wie die anderen
eu nachbarländer auch mit einer etwas
zersplitterten parteienlandschaft zu tun
oder würden sie sagen dass das hier ein
zerfall der alten machtstrukturen
also ja und nein wir haben eine
niederlegung kann man schon sagen dass
jetzt mehr parteien da sind ja für jeden
was dabei in einer bunten mittig kite
selbst wenn man jetzt sieben parteien
union zusammen rechnet mit diesen
dänischen friesischen einen abgeordneten
ist das schon viel mehr als sonst und
damit gleichen sich auch die parteien
als halbstarke parteien er an
andererseits angleichen walter haben wir
erlebt beispielsweise in mecklenburg
vorpommern wie man an die 40 prozent mit
einer partei kommt also nicht eine
partei einfach schon abschreiben dass
sie jetzt nur noch wenig werte erreicht
das würde ich nicht es geht rauf und
runter und wenn man mehr parteien hat
ist es auf jeden fall schwieriger
regierung zu bilden was ein song aus
hall unterscheidet ist diese müdigkeit
die wir haben die extreme werden ja
immer kleiner bei uns und das ist nicht
bei anderen so sein wir haben ein multi
polaris system
lagerübergreifend mit breiter mitte und
das unterscheidet uns die anderen haben
eher polare systeme die extreme und
mitte oder extreme und andere parteien
sich gegenüberstehen jetzt hat ralph
brinkhaus aber mit diesem satz wir haben
ein komisches wahlergebnis so ein
bisschen versucht zu begründen warum das
bei der union so hakelt und irgendwie
nicht rund läuft ist das in ihren augen
eine glaubhafte begründung oder ist es
das was wir dann häufig eine ausrede
nennen
souverän und sharp zu formulieren ist
hoch funktionale politikersprache und
insofern muss das nicht nur spielräume
offen halten sondern es muss auch
zustimmungsfähig bleiben ich muss immer
so formulieren dass sie am ende des
satzes die zustimmung nach habe und was
hinter der tür dort oder gedacht hinter
der tür im fraktionssaal sich abspielt
ist genau das ringen um eine mehrheit
zustimmung zu erhalten muss er jeden
satz ich kenne überlegen das kuriose
dieses wahlergebnis besteht eben darin
dass es potenziell möglich ist erstmals
in der geschichte dass zwei
kanzlerkandidaten eine mehrheit suchen
das hatten wir nicht einer der ringt um
verschiedene dass auch mal ein zweiter
eine mehrheit bildet das gab es alles
aber dass zwei moment noch zumindest in
diesen tagen das versuchen ist
ungewöhnlich und das besondere pikante
ist eben die initiative in den neuen
formaten der macht dass diese citrus
koalition praktisch grün-gelb sich jetzt
in ihrer jungen juristen gewählt von den
meisten jungen grünliberalen
[Musik]
erzählung einer neuen bürgerlichkeit
selbst aussucht ob sie schwarz oder rot
weiterarbeiten möchte das ist das ist
aus sicht der union
kurios oder wird nicht im begriff hat
der verband es ist merkwürdig mehr
merkwürdig ja das ist es natürlich und
bedarf eben auch neuer gewohnheiten es
werden einfach neue skripte
überschrieben neue praktiken
praktiziert und angewandt werden neue
erzählungen damit geworden das zeigt wie
vital das system ist ja nicht irgendwie
stangen sondern jeder versucht jetzt
etwas auch in der institution des
parlamentarischen systems daraus zu
machen wir haben erstmal teil 1 der ms
den bundestag gewählt jetzt kommt wahl 2
ist der eigentliche akt mit der
kanzlerin citrus koalition habe ich noch
nicht gehört klingt aber auch
erfrischend muss ich sagen aber jetzt
haben sie gerade gesagt ralph brinkhaus
hat versucht anschlussfähig zu bleiben
also sich so ich sag mal jetzt ein
bisschen erlaubt wischiwaschi
auszudrücken dass jeder so sagen kann ok
das geht noch klar wenn ich aber in
unsere kommentare gucke lieber professor
konnte das machen wir hier in unserer
sendung immer dann sehe ich
anschlussfähigkeit ist dann nicht
vorhanden also ich gebe einfach mal so
ein paar eindrücke wieder
horstmann norbert auf facebook diese
selbstgefällige arroganz der union ist
nur noch peinlich wenn sie einen funken
anstand hätten würden laschet und cdu
csu in die opposition gehen anstatt hier
den job zu machen herr klose auf
facebook die menschen möchten einen
wechsel sehr viele ausrufezeichen dahin
hannelore wuthe auch auf facebook ich
glaube er hat noch nie die macht herr
laschet wieder einmal eine völlige
fehleinschätzung merkels und die
abschiedsgeschenk an die cdu sieht er
lässt einen zerstrittenen haufen eduard
beschwert sich laschet hat nicht mal
courage 1 niederlage einzugestehen was
sie da getan hat er will als verlierer
ein bündnis um kanzler zu werden das ist
nicht in meinem interesse also
anschlussfähig ist das verhalten der
union zumindest jetzt nach dem bild bei
unserer zuschauerschaft ist ja nicht
gerade präsent aktiv überhaupt nicht die
würden sie das deuten warum fällt ist
der union so schwer jetzt einfach mal zu
sagen ok dat warnschuss in ofen das hat
nicht so funktioniert wie wir wollten
wir gehen mal in vier jahre in klausur
und überlegen wie wir es besser machen
können 16 jahre an der macht ist ja auch
schon ein ganz schöner ritt gewesen ja
ich mal die anschlussfähigkeit bezog
sich darauf dass brink aus eben gerade
frisch gewählt ist und der
anschlussfähig bleiben muss mit seiner
eigenen fraktion
ich habe ja dargestellt das ungewöhnlich
ist die konstellation ist hätte ja auch
sein können dass andere mutig namen in
den ring werfen und dann vielleicht auch
eine abstimmung unter mehreren
abgeordneten der fall gewesen wäre für
den fraktionsvorsitz das hat laschet
noch ein wenig verhindern können also
ist noch macht vorhanden aber die
grundsatzfrage ist man dafür das ist
legitim
es ist auch nicht moralisch verwerflich
als zweiter durchaus eine mehrheit sich
organisiert ist die frage ob man sich so
viel schuld selbst eingesteht dass man
erkennt man ist mitverantwortlich für
diese
1,6 unterschied zwischen spd
prozentpunkt unterschied und damit
zehnmal daten zur spd ein debakel an
ergebnis ausgelöst und man ist damit
auch in der rolle zu sagen wir gehen
erhobenen hauptes in die opposition und
das wir ja auch interessante
konstellation eine große unions familie
jetzt in der opposition und eben nicht
mehr die afg sondern viele plätze weiter
auch das wäre natürlich eine möglichkeit
ich diese möglichkeit kann aber nur
entstehen aus meiner sicht wenn die
älteren herren in der union mit viel
einfluss vielleicht mit al assad
sprechen und ihn zum einen rückzug
bewegen können von sich aus wird er das
nicht machen weil er nichts anderes hat
als kämpfen um dieses amt und weil er
durchaus auch eine berechtigung sieht
auch in der geschichte diese verhandlung
führen zu dürfen aber er braucht den
rückhalt der partei und nicht jeder
abgeordnete spürt man nicht jeder
ministerpräsident aso sondern würde zum
rückzug karten und ob man sich erneut in
der opposition oder nicht das ist auch
von der wissenschaft nicht einheitlich
beantwortbar man kann sich auch in
regierungsverantwortung erneuern nur als
opposition zu setzen und da sich zu
erneuern das wäre sicherlich ein fuchs
schluss jetzt haben sie gerade schon die
älteren herren in der union angesprochen
einer davon ich hoffe er ist nicht
beleidigt wenn ich ein so bezeichnen ist
markus söder ministerpräsident von
bayern der hat sich heute auch schon vor
die presse gestellt und da haben wir
einen kurzen o-ton daraus deswegen ist
es auch wichtig dass man ein
wahlergebnis respektiert dazu gehört für
mich auch vom stil wo sie an der stelle
noch einmal weil es bislang kaum erfolgt
ist wohlauf scholz gratuliere die besten
chancen kannst du zu werden hat der
zweite lauf scholz eindeutig
ja das war eindeutig herr söder war da
sehr viel eindeutiger als herr laschet
jetzt haben wir ihn aber am sonntag auch
erlebt dass er sich hinter hernach stadt
gestellt hat heute hat er ihn wieder
über bande kritisiert hat gesagt er
hätte ihn hätte auch der spd gratulieren
müssen was für ein spiel spielt markus
söder das ist irgendwie wieder hin und
her ja das spiel wirkt wie immer wieder
live in seiner
kalkulierten herzlichkeit gegenüber herr
laschet was aber nicht dazu führt dass
man die schwestern als gemeinschaft
wahrnimmt sondern in der tat nach wie
vor unterschiedlich und das haben wir
als wiederum will natürlich während des
wahlkampfs auch gespürt dass er doch der
schatten kanzlerkandidat bis zum schluss
geblieben ist
ganz anders war das in der schlüssigkeit
der einheitlichkeit beispielsweise bei
der spd diesmal wie früher genau dieses
spiel gespielt also am sonntag eine
kehrtwendung hin zu sagen auch ein
zweiter darf verhandeln das war ganz
offen sie heute wieder die reise nach
jamaika besser gar nicht antreten das
sind sehr unterschiedliche signale und
das setzt dem
vorsitzender der cdu sehr zu es kann
aber wenn er es über den der
csu-vorsitzende wieder zu einer
beschützer funktion gegenüber laschet
führen wer die cdu erpressen will aus
sicht der csu wird das nicht hinbekommen
da passt die frage von nat dazu auf
youtube lieber professor korte wie
schätzen sie die zukünftige rolle von
markus söder ein falls es zu jamaika
gesprächen kommt
naja falls es dazu kommt wird er
natürlich über
dubiose angekündigt und mit ihm selbst
natürlich hälftig an den gesprächen
beteiligt sein und
versuchen möglichst viel an schwarz in
diese buntheit mit einzubringen dass
davon sie gehe ich aus dass er das
konstruktiv macht brendels zu diesen
gesprächen nicht versucht das instruktiv
zu handhaben weil für ihn das ist
wichtig dass er immer aus seiner sicht
viel für csu damit die bayern ausland
für ihn ist wichtig dass eine gute
startposition hat für die kommende
landtagswahl in zwei jahren so damit bei
ihnen das telefon das ist ein schöner
hinweis dass hier vielleicht mal kurz
einen beitrag uns angucken nämlich armin
laschet der jetzt natürlich viel
kritisierten gescholten wird hat aber
auch schon einen ziemlich schwierigen
weg hinter sich thomas garcia hartmann
zusammengefasst was da passiert ist seit
seiner kandidatur als cdu
parteivorsitzender
[Musik]
das kanzleramt in reichweite vor wenigen
monaten schien das mehr als möglich für
armin laschet die union in umfragewerten
oben laschets karriere weist in die
gleiche richtung
im januar setzt er sich als
parteivorsitzender durch gegen norbert
röttgen und friedrich merz die
delegierten überzeugt seiner arbeit als
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen seit 2017 regiert er
das bevölkerungsreichste bundesland
stabil trotz knapper mehrheit zusammen
mit den liberalen sein ziel schwarz gelb
auch im bund
april laschet erklärt er wolle als
kanzlerkandidat antreten sollte
ebenfalls der zieht aber zurück die
parteiführung ist nicht auf seiner seite
obwohl er die besseren umfragewerte hat
die von laschet dagegen sinken in einem
wahlkampf mit pannen verheerende bilder
etwa bei besuchen im flutgebiet
noch am wahltag unterläuft ihm ein
fehler
in der nacht auf montag dann das
ergebnis laut schätzungen hinter der spd
knapp 2 aber nun ist klar das kanzleramt
es ist nicht mehr gerückt für armin
laschet
so und er gibt das muntere diskussionen
bei uns unter den zuschauern welche
koalition jetzt eigentlich
wahrscheinlicher wäre und wer was davon
hat einmal von polit man 1 0 1 die ich
verstehe die ganze aufregung nicht es
gibt zwei möglichkeiten die regierung zu
bilden letztlich werden grüne und fdp
das entscheiden also ein sehr
entspannter umgang damit aber patrick
schreib dir zum beispiel ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass es eine jamaika
koalition geben wird hier schaltet drauf
ich erst mal kurz da ist die cdu wäre
die einzige partei und dreierbündnis die
davon profitieren würde was müsste
eigentlich passieren herr professor
korte dass die grünen und die fdp sagen
also mit der spd das funktioniert nicht
wo sehen sie da tatsächlich die größten
schwierigkeiten
ich möchte nur mal darauf hinweisen dass
eine dritte alternative gibt die coco
unter scholz führung vermutlich danone
vizekanzler scholz laschet sondern mit
einem anderen das ist das strategische
potenzial was nämlich die spd und auch
die cdu haben dass sie sagen können wir
werden uns nicht völlig preis wäre nicht
alles preisgeben wir wollen die rote
farbe die schwarze farbigen
koalitionsverhandlung auch erkennen und
wer das übertreibt aus der citrus
koalition wird am ende gar nicht
beteiligt weil diese option ist da die
schließlich nicht aus wenn also eine
blockierte situation entsteht dass das
nicht machbar ist rechne ich damit dass
steinmeier die fatalen wieder ins kann
die ins schloss bellevue ein bestellen
wird und darauf drängt dass bitte eine
regierung zu bilden es aus der mitte des
parlaments weil dafür ja viele parteien
zur verfügung steht also aber was am
ende einfacher wird oder schwerer wird
bisher linken gab alle in die
unterschiedlichen richtungen um sich
optionen offen zu halten also warum mit
kolportiert dass herr lindner stunden
lagen mit der lasche telefoniert warum
wird immer erzählt dass es in düsseldorf
alles so gut läuft das ist auch gut
gelaufen aus sicht von beiden natürlich
um drohpotenzial zu haben gegenüber dem
der spd und umgekehrt wird man von den
grünen auch dass vielleicht die grund
sympathien er bei der ampel und damit
rot sind als beispiele sind das
strategische gespräche die nach außen
dringen die aber nichts aussagen darüber
wie man sich einige könnte die
möglichkeiten mit interessanten
narrativen entlang zb der freiheits
erzählung die ja rot grün gelb
gleichermaßen haben freiheit er über
eine senkung des staates wie es habe
immer betont hat oder freiheit im sinne
individueller freiheit hier ist der
liberalen tradition angelegt ist solche
erzählungen vielleicht zu verbinden mit
der respekt erzählung der spd die mit
lebensleistung der
bürger auch über das thema arbeit
verknüpft ist dass solche punkte darauf
müssten wir in zukunft achten denn die
vereinbarung über details die lassen
sich herausstellte wie weit man als eine
erzählung die politik treiber sein kann
um etwas neues zu entziehen und diese
inszenierung nicht nur auf dem papier
sondern auch so ansteckt dass sie
begeistert wenn mit einer idee man eine
lern koalition hinbekommt dann
überspringt man auch widerstände und
unterschiede diese idee gemeinsam zur
not auszuloten die sollte und wird
wahrscheinlich auch gegenstand der
regierung sein und nicht welche
steuersätze man irgendwo hinter der
zweite punkt ist ganz zentral die logik
des sozial vertraut man sich geht man
davon aus dass die menschen die hier
zusammensitzen auch nur dass in dem raum
belassen was man gerade spricht klingt
das nicht nach außen das ist viel
wichtiger als details inhaltlicher art
und wenn das nicht gegeben ist von der
persönlichen chemie her oder fairgrounds
mäßig man das missbraucht wird es nie zu
weiteren verhandlungen kommen also die
entscheidung über diese koalition hängt
nicht davon ab ob man unüberbrückbarer
team hat sondern vom typus der koalition
von der
vertrauensbasis und auch von der
erzählung also da haben wir jetzt die
großen linien aber es gibt noch eine
vierte option die wird eigentlich fast
nie besprochen aber in den kommentaren
immer wieder erwähnt von der böse watts
auf youtube warum denken sie professor
korte haben die politiker so ein bammel
vor einer minderheitsregierung das wäre
doch demokratie pur wäre denkbar union
und spd und grüne sagen zum beispiel wir
versuchen eine regierung zu bilden und
die fdp holen wir ins boot bei
bestimmten punkten das könnte union und
fdp genau so machen und versuchen die
grünen irgendwie dazu zu bewegen doch
bei manchen punkten mitzumachen oder ist
das alles einfach schon aus deutscher
tradition heraus völlig undenkbar ja wir
haben das in ländern ja gab zuletzt in
nrw über zweieinhalb jahre immerhin
alles der größten europäischen länder
hat das auch funktioniert wir haben es
tageweise bund jama gehabt aber unsere
politische kultur von sicherheits
deutschen verliebten wählerinnen und
wähler setzt auf stabilität auf
berechenbarkeit auch durch diese
multilateralen einbindung international
geht man davon aus dass berechenbarkeit
ein wichtiges kriterium es wie bereichen
war ist eine regierung die sich
permanent zu jedem thema eine neue
mehrheit suchen soll das ist für uns
ungewohnt aber es kann funktionieren vor
allen dingen ist ist politikmanagement
was eine super vitalisierung von allen
abgeordneten bedeutet nicht das
kanzleramt entscheiden sondern aus der
mitte des parlaments sucht man sich eine
idee der problemlösung versucht damit
eine mehrheit zu bekommen jeder
abgeordnete wird viel wichtiger als er
jetzt ist es hat also auch vorteile aber
das passt nicht zu unserer sehr
sicherheits verliebte und mit dieser wir
haben ja auch nicht klar gewählt so
beispielsweise in schwerin hat na klar
wir haben tag wer einfach bund gewählt
wir gehen auf nummer sicher jeder selbst
die dänische minderheit soll dabei sein
niemand nimmt alleinverantwortung
sondern alles irgendwie beteiligt in
dieser aufgeregtheit zu sagen wir wollen
veränderung und wir wollen status quo so
eine stabile ambivalenz das lieben
das ist eine sehr schöne analyse der
deutschen befindlichkeit ich habe jetzt
hier noch eine frage bevor sie nochmal
zu der frage kommen wie es bei der union
endlich weitergeht weil die auch immer
wieder gestellt wird nochmal ein rechner
schalten leyen pinguin ich frage mich
wie groß die möglichkeit ist da
vierten ist dass es neuwahlen geben wird
sehen sie das irgendwo als mit einer
chance dass das nein ich sehe dass nach
ein paar wochen journalisten wieder
sagen und ausrufen aber überall neuwahl
so ist das ja über viele wochen auch
damals gewesen vor vier jahren und dann
als die große koalition bestand hat man
über monate immer das thema gehört wann
bricht sie auseinander nein das ganze
ist auf stabilität ausgerichtet durch
das grundgesetz ist sehr voraussetzungen
bundeskanzler bundestag bundespräsident
müssen alle zusammenarbeiten und müssen
aus wege finden über vertrauensfragen
die misslingen oder konstruktive
misstrauensvoten die miss legen und so
weiter also die kunst in negativer zu
denken um so etwas zu bekommen wir haben
kein selbstauflösung des rechts des
deutschen bundestages wies schiede der
landesparlamente haben sofern halte ich
das für sehr unwahrscheinlich zumal wir
wirklich sehen soll dass ganz viele
mitte parteien existieren die durchaus
mehrheitsfähig sein können wir haben
jetzt sogar zwei kannst du zur auswahl
da muss man doch irgendwie der mehrheit
hinbekommen ich halte es für also
neuwahlen schließlich komplett aus gut
ich mir ist es sehr wichtig zu betonen
gerade dass die frage nicht von mir kam
sondern von zuschauer in immer wieder
gestellt wird aber wenn journalisten
kollegen in den nächsten wochen mit der
frage kommen können wir sie an sie
verweisen kommen wir noch mal zurück zu
der diskussion um die union sie haben
gerade gesagt die deutschen lieben
eigentlich die status quo im wandel aber
gerade die union ist ein gratis nach den
ganz anderen eindruck also es ist eher
ein aufgeregter hühnerhaufen habe ich
das ein bisschen das gefühl von außen
wir betrachten uns als mannschaft sagte
ralph brinkhaus der jetzt ja erstmal für
ein halbes jahr gewählte neue fraktions
und alte fraktionsvorsitzende ist das
auch ihr eindruck oder ist das pfeifen
im wald das ist praktisch eine
mannschaft die aber sich
konstituiert über eine lose verkoppelt
anarchie der er vorsteht das ist nicht
viel mehr denn er wird vermutlich eher
geduldet aber untersuchen und anarchie
das passt in meinem kopf nicht zusammen
ja aber das passt im moment noch in der
union wenn man so
gedemütigt wird so ein macht stieg
szenarium kopf hat solche debakel hat an
wahlergebnissen und sich damit nur
rettet das andere auch keine super
ergebnisse haben da
lässt sich viel und da sind praktisch
auch prozesse der macht erosion mit
einer richtigen potenzial zumindest dass
der charme der diskrete charme der
anarchie liegt auch über dieser fraktion
weil natürlich man versucht sich auch
irgendwie zu retten wie schafft man die
position die ein für vier jahre in eine
bessere lage bringt das doch genau die
überlegung wenn die mannschaft die jetzt
die verantwortung hatte die letzten
monate offenbar nicht den erfolg
gebracht hat die man sich gewünscht hat
aus vielerlei gründen insofern sehe ich
nicht dass das kraftvolle
geschlossenheit ist als mannschaft dass
man einer bestimmten linie folgt sondern
da werden ganz viele eigenen wege neu
frisch aktiviert die union hat bisher
leise gelitten damit hat sie sich
ausgezeichnet abgesetzt von allen anna
ich glaube dieses dieser leise
leidensweg ist vorbei das wird jetzt
offensiver jetzt gibt es aber auch schon
die ersten rücktrittsforderungen aus den
reihen der union die werte union das ist
jetzt nicht tatsächlich ein teil der
union aber es sind unionsmitglieder drin
hat sich dafür ausgesprochen einzelne
abgeordnete haben entsteht schon
aufgefordert jetzt seien die anlage
einzugestehen und zu gehen was meinen
sie wie lange hält er das noch aus
er ist ein großer kämpfer ein
leidenschaftlicher verhandler und auch
clever dabei auch strategisch unterwegs
ich würde ihn niemals unterschätzen in
seiner langlebigkeit seiner politischen
langlebigkeit aber es ist doch klar
irgendwann kann es sein dass er auch
erkennen muss dass er sich mit den
nächsten tagen wichtigen entscheidungen
nicht durchsetzt heute alle sich noch
einmal durchgesetzt und dann wenn die
macht so zerbröckelt wird es für ihn
schwierig neue entscheidungen
herbeizuführen und es kann eben sein
dass elder statesman aus der partei auf
ihn zukommen und sagen es ist jetzt über
reids das bringt für uns alle nicht
lass es lieber sein auch solche momente
gibt es in der politik aber wie passt
das zusammen wenn sie jetzt sagen herr
laschet ist jemand der gibt nicht auf er
ist ein kämpfer der denkt strategisch
das bild hatte in den letzten wochen des
wahlkampfes nicht wirklich hinterlassen
woran lag das er hat ja nicht aufgegeben
hat bis zuletzt persönlich gekämpft hat
fehler gemacht das ist doch ganz klar
aber ich kann jetzt nicht erkennen dass
ja irgendwie sicherheit beeinträchtigen
beeinflussen lassen von negativer
berichterstattung und von den eigenen
fehlern die ja auch immer wieder dazu
gegeben hat es ist ja eine eine
abwärtsspirale die erkennbar war am ende
war es ja so wenn er auch über wasser
gelaufen hätte hätten die leute mit
sicherheit gesagt guck mal der kann noch
nicht mal schwimmen also egal was er
gemacht hat er hatte sich gegen ihn
gewendet aber er hat trotzdem ja keinen
einzigen termin abgesagt er hat das
durchgezogen und so meine ich dass er
sei ein kämpfer weil er hat einmal den
auftrag bekommen ist zu machen dann
macht das auch immer versucht das beste
daraus zu machen das kann man auch
verstehen was wäre es und er hat nichts
anderes auch wenn er das
abgeordnetenmandat annehmen muss er auch
das mandat in düsseldorf abgeben es kein
ministerpräsidenten erst noch
parteivorsitzender vermutlich dann auf
zeit er ist normaler abgeordneter jetzt
ja nicht fraktionsvorsitzender
ihm bleibt um das politische überleben
für sich selbst zu sichern nur die
chance nach jamaika zu reisen und sich
vielleicht rastalocken wachsen zu lassen
das ist ein schönes bild professor korte
danke ihm dafür für diese ja für diesen
schlussworte und für diese spielt in
meinem kopf
bayern laschet vielleicht noch gut ich
danke ihnen und bin gespannt auf die
nächsten tage und wochen erst mal einen
schönen ja gerne ihnen auch so und ein
kleines schlusswort möchte ich noch
richten an
kritiker hier im stream die meinten nur
weil wir uns hier kritisch mit der cdu
beschäftigen würden wir uns klar zur spd
positionieren das hat er da gerade
gemacht auf facebook das ist nicht der
fall bitte nicht verwechseln die
kritische auseinandersetzung mit einer
partei die gerade sehr ins straucheln
gerät das müssen wir so begleiten das
hat nichts damit zu tun dass wir
irgendeine partei präferieren würden
wäre das zdf von innen kennt der wird
außen vorschreiben können insofern danke
ich für eure aufmerksamkeit für eure
kommentare und fragen wie immer und sagt
bis zum nächsten spiel macht gut und
tschüss